is Marvel in trouble this is the
headline and it is also on the cover
piece for a new Variety article an
article where they Deep dive into the
problems at Marvel recently and all of
the drama that has been happening at
Marvel Studios as well you may have
heard some of the topics of this article
be mentioned in videos recently like the
news that Marvel Studios may not only be
considering recasting Jonathan major for
the role of King but also possibly
getting rid of Kang the Conqueror in
general in the MCU and possibly be
replacing him with Dr Doom or the news
that Marvel Studios may be considering
bringing back Robert Downey Jr Scarlett
Johansson and Chris Evans for the next
part of the MCU for the MCU reboot in
this video we'll break down the entire
article go over the entire thing and
tell you exactly what you need to know
and there is a lot to dive into and if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for chance to one Xbox series X a PS5
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner picks one item and we
pick a winner at the end of each month
so the article starts off by giving us a
little bit of tea some inside
information about what Marvel Studios
has been up to it starts off by stating
this past September a group of Marvel
creatives including Studio Chief Kevin
feige assembled in Palm Springs for the
Studio's annual Retreat then it says
most years the vibe would have been
confident even cocky given how the
premier superhero brand owned by Disney
since 2009 has remade the entertainment
business in its image but this occasion
was angst written everyone at Marvel was
reeling from a series of disappointments
on screen a legal Scandal involving one
of its biggest stars and questions about
the viability of the studios's ambitious
strategy to extend the brand Beyond
movies into streaming it basically
States all of the problems that we know
Marvel Studios has been going through
lately the movies haven't been that
successful their streaming shows haven't
been that successful either the Marvels
is looking to severely underperform at
the box office and of course we have the
troubles that Jonathan major has been in
recently in which variety went on to say
the most pressing issue to be discussed
at the retreat was what to do about
Jonathan Majors they went on to say at
the Gathering in Palm Springs Executives
discussed backup plans including
pivoting to another comic book adversary
like Dr Doom but making any shift would
carry its own headaches in which of
course they then go on to talk about how
he was the main villain and Ant-Man and
the WASP Quantum Mania the post credit
scene set him and his variant up to be
the main villain of course we have King
Dynasty and of course Loki season 2 and
season one has set him up to be a major
player but as we heard here from variety
at this Retreat Marvel Studios talked
about plans to possibly replace Kang
with Dr Doom that's how serious the
situation with Jonathan Majors is right
now and also it's not just Majors but
the character as well because they could
simply go on to recast Jonathan major as
Kang simply get another actor to
continue playing King the Conqueror but
they're considering the lack of success
that Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania
had might be due to lack of interest in
King the Conqueror to the point to where
if it doesn't work out with Jonathan
major they might just bring in Dr Doom
which right away go ahead and let us
know what you think about that would you
prefer that or would you like to see
Kang stick around I know Doom is loved
by the fandom he's most likely the
greatest Marvel villain of all time if
not definitely top five but let us know
what you would think if Marvel Studios
decided to replace Kang with Dr Doom
depending on how you look at it this is
is actually great news and since the
Fantastic Four are coming they could
work in Dr Doom somehow and it does
sound like Jonathan major might not be
sticking around because one Insider said
this Marvel is truly effed with the
whole Kang angle says one top dealmaker
who has seen the final Loki episode and
he continued to State and they haven't
had an opportunity to rewrite until very
recently because of the writer strikes
but I don't see a plan to how they move
forward with him so Marvel Studios might
be repping to get rid of Kang and bring
in Doom of course this is not official
the decision has not been made yet but
Marvel Studios is seriously considering
this it then goes on to talk about how
the Marvels is looking to severely
underperform at the box office and how
this is basically a new problem for
Marvel because everything from Iron Man
to Avengers endgame was for the most
part a pretty big success and here's
where they go on to kind of talk about
the flaw in Marvel's new plan moving
forward with the start of phase 4 they
state replicating that kind of
phenomenon is never easy however the
source of Marvel's current troubles can
be traced back to 2020 that's when Co
pandemic ushered in a mandate to help
boost Disney's stock price with an
endless torrent of interconnected Marvel
content for the studios fledging
streaming platform Disney plus and
here's where we really start to
understand what Marvel studios's plan
was they said according to the plan
there would never be a lapse in
superhero fair with either a film in
theaters or a new television series
streaming at any given moment but the
ensuing tsunami of spandex proved to be
too much of a good thing and the demands
of churning out so much programming tax
the Marvel apparatus then they State
this line which I probably believe is
the true reason Marvel Studios hasn't
had that much success recently they
State moreover the need to tease out an
interwoven storyline over so many
dispirit shows movies and platforms
created a muddled narrative that baffled
viewers I know a lot of fans have
complained that there just doesn't feel
like there's that much connectivity in
the MCU anymore a lot of people have
also complained that there's just simply
too much content and they're not
interested in all of it but you kind of
have to watch it a little bit at least
to know what's going to happen maybe in
the future just saying that sentence is
kind of exhausting in itself so I can
understand how fans feel the article
says the machine was pumping out a lot
of content did it get to the point where
there was just too much and they were
burning people out on superheroes it's
possible says Wall Street analyst Eric
hler who covers Disney the more you do
the tougher it is to maintain quality
they tried experimenting with breaking
in some new characters like shangi and
internals with mixed results with
budgets as big as these you need home
runs and I would agree with the
maintaining quality statement the
quality hasn't really been there but in
this article we actually learn about
some quality factors that have been
lacking and why and one of those is the
postproduction and the VFX a source of
varieties that was close on the
production of the Marvels stated Kevin's
real superpower his genius has always
been in post- production and getting his
hands on movies and making sure that
they are finished strongly these days
he's spread thin and of course he is
before it was only two three movies a
year now it's three four movies a year
and 3 four five possibly six Disney Plus
shows and special presentations so one
is fige has not really been able to be
as involved with all of these projects
like he was before and another problem
of course is the VFX which fans have
complained about a lot however in this
article we find out a different core
root of that problem with the VFX and
apparently it is the scripting and Story
the article talks about Victoria Alonzo
being fired because she was in charge of
the post- production and when they
started to get some poor VFX out there
she was let go that's the very short
story of it but variety goes on to state
that some internal sources suggest
Alonzo was a scapegoat and point to the
She-Hulk VFX issues as a symptom of a
deeper route namely a lack of oversight
on script development in the original
Arc of She-Hulk a flashback of star
Tatiana manan's transformation into her
whole character didn't take place until
episode 8 but after Marvel's Brain Trust
watch footage it realized the scene
needed to happen in the pilot episode
episode 1 so that audiences could see
more of the character's backstory early
on that meant that the VFX team was
tasked with fixing the mess in
post-production the so-called bad VFX we
see was because of half Bak scripts says
one person involved with She-Hulk that
is not Victoria that is not Kevin and
even above Kevin those issues should be
addressed in pre-production the timeline
is not allowing the Marvel Executives to
sit with the material so some of those
those VFX problems that we thought were
just bad VFX were really actually due to
the script now of course the VFX workers
were working really long hours and
according to some sources weren't
getting paid that well which is why they
decided to unionize so there were
several factors but it wasn't just the
VFX team being bad at their jobs it was
the deadlines and the pressure and the
things that weren't in their control
like the changing of scripts that all
contributed to it and all the meanwhile
Kevin fogy being spread too thin to
really dive into things like he used to
before phase 4 in Disney Plus they then
end the section on this by quoting
Joanna Robinson the co-author of the New
York Times bestseller now MCU the reign
of Marvel Studios stating this the
quality is suffering in 2019 at the peak
if you put Marvel Studios in front of
something people were like oh that brand
means quality that Association is no
longer the case because there have been
so many projects that felt Half Baked
and undercooked and unfortunately as
much as I do love Marvel Studios and the
MCU that kind of is the case because
they have had some projects the most
recently underperform and not really be
fully well thought out Half Baked and
undercooked is a pretty decent way to
describe it but they then go on to talk
about the good kind of in a way but
basically the future they State as
public criticism mounts feige is pulling
the plug on scripts and projects that
aren't working case in point the blade
reboot they say it looked promising but
the project has gone through at least
five Riders two directors and one shut
down 6 weeks before production one
person familiar with the script
premutations say the story at one point
morphed into a narrative led by woman
and filled with life lessons blade was
relegated to the fourth lead a bizarre
idea considering that the studio had
two-time Oscar winner Ali on board amid
reports that Ali was ready to exit over
script issues feige went back to the
drawing board and hired Michael Green
the Oscar nominated writer of Logan to
start a new sounds like blade might
actually be in Jeopardy and there is a
chance that it might not happen because
Mersa Ali might actually bail if the
script doesn't continue to get better
we've heard reports recently that that
might be the case but let's cross our
fingers and hope that isn't true but it
continues to state with Iger publicly
acknowledging the downside of a Marvel
TV glut that diluted focus and attention
the keepers of the comic book Empire are
considering some dramatic moves sources
say there have been talks to bring back
the original gang for an Avengers movie
this would include Reviving Robert
Downey Jr's Iron Man and Scarlett
Johansson's Black Widow both of whom
were killed off in endgame however they
state but the studio hasn't yet
committed to the idea if it were able to
bring these actors back it wouldn't come
cheap sources say Downey Junior's
upfront salary for Iron Man 3 was around
25 million so here you have it a huge
Outlet like variety with their own
sources confirming Marvel Studios is
indeed truly considering bringing back
the original Avengers for another
Avengers movie and since the Multiverse
is in effect now that shouldn't really
be that big of an issue especially with
a soft reboot as well now this article
also went on to talk about the Marvels
and the problems that they have had but
we've done a lot of videos on those and
it's everything that we've heard before
so we're going to skip that part
basically to summarize they have a new
director who hasn't exactly been saying
the best things about the movie like she
had to call Dustin Daniel keton director
of shangi on set and ask what any of it
even means showing her lack of knowledge
about the MCU then of course they
recently did some re-shoot for the post
credit scene which we've been talking
about recently that's going to have a
fox X-Men character but of course the
box office is looking to be very
underwhelming as well and of course
they've had to do a lot of reshoots
before and they had to move their data
back a bunch that's basically what they
talk about but they end on some very
important notes concerning Jonathan
major and the recasting they State a
studio Source notes that regardless of
the actor's legal issues Marvel already
had considered moving away from a
Major's Le phase because of the box
office performance of quantum Mania and
they say that Marvel is not afraid to
make changes and make waves so Jonathan
major and Kang possibly being out might
be a real thing and possibly Doom coming
in is a very very realistic reality and
then the final thing the article ends
with is this the key to reinvigorating
Marvel May lie with the superhero
Arsenal that Disney acquired during its
2019 purchase of 20th Century Fox that
deal brought several Blue Chip Heroes
such as the X-Men and the Fantastic 4
back under the Studio's control already
fans are gigging out about the next
year's Deadpool 3 which unites Ryan
Reynolds MK with the mouth with Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine and a reboot of a
Fantastic Four slated for 2025 as a
bonus the fox editions give F an
opportunity to reimagine the X-Men
franchise the very property he cut his
teeth on as a young executive at Lauren
Schuler Donner's production company now
that the wga strike is in the rearview
mirror Marvel has started talking to
writers about bringing the X-Men into
the MCU fold while feige recalibrates
the rest of the industry is anxiously
hoping that Marvel's best days are not
behind it writing the Marvel obituary
would be ill advised says Jason Squire
professor ameritus at USC School of
cinematic arts and host of the movie
business podcast Kevin fagy is the Babe
Ruth of movie Executives and Marvel has
the most profitable track record in
movie history no question and that is
the end of the article so certainly a
lot has been happening at Marvel Studios
but hey they entered into a new realm
with Disney plus and yeah they were
stretched too thin because they didn't
anticipate all that it would take to
really get everything done so we have to
keep in mind that this all was very new
for Marvel Studios But as time goes by
they should get better at it and in
Kevin F could we trust because he did do
an incredible job with the infinity Saga
plus like they State the X-Men and the
Fantastic 4 are coming and they could be
the key to reinvigorating Marvel as well
as bringing some of the old characters
like Iron Man Black Widow and Captain
America back but we also know that Kevin
figy is really working on making Marvel
better so hopefully that is exactly what
is going to happen but hey we just
unpacked a lot of information let us
know all of your thoughts about this in
the comments down below and to keep
staying up to date on Marvel news be
sure to subscribe so you miss out on any
of the latest videos you can also find
us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf woof